pour le moment et bien je vous laisse en
compagnie de pierre de glace à tout à
l'heure vous avez manqué ça me manquait
j'ai fait un petit trou et ses célèbres
chinois les coins
j'appelle les bambous sinon les
baguettes chinoises c'est un tout très
essentielle des nazis alors je
connaissais pas du tout elle
reconnaissait que les japonais ils
fabriquent tous les objectifs que menu
sans voix et vous pensez que moi je te
quitte comprendre c'est pas mal et
comprend pas tellement puisque comme la
notice il écrit en japonais
j'étais déçu ils s'élèvent tout ça oui
et c'est patricia élèves très difficile
même nom mais ne touche pas ah non
monsieur touche pas mais j'ai le fils
enfin ça me paraît quand même assez
facile non bah oui en bas c'est normal
les leurs ils s'installent chez compris
non grata dans la notice des japonais
jgc et république il voit pas les petits
fichiers
oui enfin là quand même peu quand même
ça se voit nettement non toulouse vient
ça peut-être les japonais ne voit pas
que c'est pour ça qu'ils sont des
lunettes tous les versants nord est où
maintenant
et maintenant il n'ya pas de plus parce
que comment j'ai coupé
oui on va voir si ça marche on va tirer
comme ça ça ne marche pas mal il est
comme ça si ça marche ça maintenant
pourquoi moi je te pas le flair qui
chantent mais sympa alors attendez j'ai
cru comprendre mais je serais incapable
de vous l'expliquer ce qui fait quand
même plus qu il y en a sûrement qu'un
truc et des contrastes et y en a deux de
mettre le cul
bon eh ben je vous remercie beaucoup
mais quand même je m'expliquais ça après
là on vous laisse en compagnie de pierre
douglas
[Musique]